[Music]
I mean we're over and I see people have
left we're overtime but if anybody has
any questions they haven't thrown us out
yet so let's Max you know let's use the
time if anybody has any questions uh I'm
sure many of the 911 family members
would be happy to take questions yes
counselor had said to you or had said
that they did oppose the mosque but
could not oppose it openly what
explanation did he give did he give it
because of reelection did he say he was
afraid of protests well at he was a
newly elected Democratic councilman of
uh my area in Queens I won't give his
name right now and um he said it was he
sort of indicated it was you know very
political I also spoke with our assembly
woman and they did ask me to come to
their office uh uh so I do plan on going
to their office and I'm going to
pressure them into asking about why was
it considered a party matter did they
imply that at all uh they thought it was
political they said it was political I
mean he didn't go to detail but he did
ask me to come see him very interested
in what he says yes yes and but I do
urge everybody to write I think if
people write their congressmen and their
councilman they have to feel the
pressure I mean that's all I can they
respond to that are there any Muslim
groups at all that have spoken out
against de is there any you mentioned
some moderates that is there any
organized group is there any I've never
heard
any jaon has spoken out against the M
the problem is Judy jasser zudi jasser
excuse me represents zudi jasser I mean
you know he he he lives in his own sort
of private Islam and uh he he was thrown
out of his MK so I do believe that there
are Muslims uh the problem with with if
they come out against the MOs they have
to live in their communities they have
to live in their communities have they
go back to their mosque it's not just
their family it's very difficult for
them to speak out I get anonymous emails
from Muslims I understand I don't have
to go to the mosque I don't have to live
in that community and it's there's a lot
of pressure so well I can tell you
anonymously yes they write to me has any
group did I mean Ro um r r the group
come out or was it just her it was just
her singular Muslims have come out but
these groups like The coun of America
Islamic relations and Islamic society
America these are Muslim Brotherhood
fronts so they're never going to oppose
the
mosque yes oh
yeah um two quick points of the first
one in regards to many Muslim groups not
actually coming out because they're
afraid of persecution I'm often going
take taking myself back to the 1920s
with the Kuku clan in which we could say
that Loosely that would be Christian
extremism if you could even Define it as
such but if we wish to call it that it
was Christians within their own
communities in the Deep South that
resisted the Kuku clan that actually
defeated the Kuku Clan so should we not
expect
true of course true I I'm not saying
anyway the clan is Christian I'm just
saying that people within their own
communities took the stand at their own
personal risk and I think we should
respect the same from moderate Muslim
communities that they need to make the
they need to step up and work with us to
resist
this true I don't think you can expect
it Muslims to speak out against
extremism in their communities but where
are they they don't exist we're going to
be waiting for those guys till doomsday
exactly we can't depend on them I
totally what is a moderate musle a
compromis mus a secular secular it's a
secular Muslim secular it's not about
Muslim the question that I have though
is that I'm Liberty student Liberty
University of inber Virginia and I
noticed that we have recently got an
Islamic Center that has come to our
small town in the heart of Virginia I
did a little of my own personal research
and was able to find that this Islamic
Center and the MOs that was built by the
Airport Virginia is tied with Islamic
groups in New York City and Washington
DC that have Brad terrorists out of
their group now I cannot identify where
the funing is but for those of us who
wish to act against Jihad within our own
little communities how do we go about
finding where Islamic groups get their
money and then bring it to the proper
authorities for these MOS to be
investigated by either the FBI or by
some other government bureaucracy that
may be able to help us get rid of these
groups it's a tricky question uh the
money it's a tricky question really the
best way to begin the search is to
search the groups the groups uh
notoriously many of ones you're you're
discussing are tied to the Muslim
Brotherhood and under the Freedom of
Information Act and if they you know 501
c3s their books are supposed to be open
now many times they don't open their
books and then you have to make you have
to make a public SN about it this is
really what you have to do you have to
have a game a ground game you have to
have a legal game you have to pursue
every single Avenue which is how they do
that's how they Advance their agenda
it's a very good question but I strongly
recommend first the ties first document
the ties that will lead you uh through a
maze but it will lead you at the end to
where you want to be
thanks out of 48 city council
persons only one thinks that this should
not be built and out of all the Congress
people in that nobody thinks that this
is
reprehensible Peter my Governor uh in
the state of New Jersey um Chris
Christie who everyone tting as a
wonderful uh presidential had will not
stand up and say I am against this moth
and you know what they can tell him all
he wants all they want if he's not
willing to stand up and say I am against
this MOS because of X Y and Z then he is
not worthy of ever being considered a
president of the United
States like you said they speak out and
it was right before election and they
didn't want to lose their election
because the rally in June 6th one C the
councilman from Staten Island was the
only one at that rally and he spoke out
against it and he did not get reelected
if that had anything to do with it I
don't know what I think it may have and
the same with that politicians that are
in office right now they do business
where is their Investments going Mayor
Bloomberg has investments in duai and he
this is his third term which he sort of
sold himself into it and then now he's
in there and he's doing making all these
decisions
and he has investments into why he
really is not interested in what's
happening in New York right now I just
wanted to to parot on what Joy said we
better wake up yes they not gone away
we're here to remind you they're not
gone away they're not going away and
America has forgotten and they're going
to attack again as sure as we're sitting
up here we're going to tell you that
today and you know what you're
politicians you can thank every every
single one of them if we get attacked
again cuz you know what I think the CIA
the FBI the president the Congress
nobody is taking care of us
anymore yeah my question is for mainly
Pam um Grover norquist said yesterday
that um that making an issue out of the
mosque um making an issue out of the
mosque and the Sharia law thing um he
said that he he wants it to go away
because he doesn't think it'll work and
he said he wants it to go away because
it's the wrong thing to do and I was
wondering if maybe you could respond to
that well I want the Sharia law to go
away cuz I don't think that'll
work this is the problem with CP we want
Grover to go away this that's right this
is the problem is the problem with CPAC
that it's corrupted and it's been
compromised by Muslim Brotherhood op and
12,000 people that come the 12,000
people this is why I do my events here
every year I do an event because if you
look at the agenda of CPAC look at look
at all of the panels and then look at
your daily news headlines they're either
clueless or complicit okay right and I
believe it's the lad and I and I'm
telling you that before you throw the
baby out with the bath water are there
are 12,000 people that come to this
event that don't know that they've been
completely sold out by CPAC leadership
we have to take CPAC back you can't
create this again you're not going to
create an event where 12,000 people come
you know how hard that is to do why do
we have to walk away from something so
great with the people that are coming
the people are coming here to be
activated keep be sold to the highest
bid the Ron paans and so it's ridiculous
I'm sorry it's ridiculous I going to
vote you understand I'm saying so he
he's got gr's got to go sule's got to go
you know those checks the copies of
those checks by the Muslim Brotherhood
Keen is going to go I see that Keen is
leaving that's fine but he's really a
figurehead that board has to go and the
people have to know what's going on and
the right doesn't want to run these
articles that I write because we don't
want to eat our own and I say that ain't
our own that's right
[Applause]
who else yes yes I've been following
this issue I've been following this
issue for uh quite some time I person uh
yes I'm a student I person I personally
um actually got into this whole issue I
read um a book called the end of Faith
by Sam Harris and that's what really
woke me up to the Spectre of Islamic
radicalism and I've always felt that all
free men and the all free men and women
in the world World be they Christians
Jews agnostic atheists Hindus Muslims of
conscience should be Allied in this
whole effort to oppose the biggest
threat to Freedom that exists right now
have you guys um any of you on this
panel right here how successful have you
been at networking uh such diverse uh
groups of people to this common cause
which threats us
all this you found us
that have been uh you know uh the
victims of you know Jihadi Wars over
what 85 million 85 million H have
slaughtered
zarrian uh any freedom loving people yes
we have a common cause the problem is we
have a media that's absolutely corrupt
we have a media that promotes an Islamic
supremacist agenda so we have to find
each other this way anybody else want to
add to this people are 911 family
members are so afraid of offending too
people are so afraid of offending other
people the say the the Muslim people
because the media has managed to paint
us as wacko bigots so who wants to be
labeled that I mean even for my own
children they understand what I'm doing
down here today but to explain to them
that you know Mommy doesn't hate all the
Muslim it's hard for people to wrap
their head around well why wouldn't you
want a mosque what what harm would it do
down there it it takes a while for
people to realize you got got to stand
up for it and not be afraid what the
media throws at you what other people
think of you you have to stand up for
what you believe in it's very hard for
people to do that they're afraid of
being labeled they're afraid of being
thought of as oh those 911 family
members who can't get over it can't they
just get over it didn't they get enough
money like it's all that so you get all
that baggage you got to listen to people
saying you got enough money you're a 911
family member you should just be quiet
now little 9/11 family member we paid
you enough money so so go home be quiet
and don't let it bother us for and it's
an opportunity to put people on the spot
God has a wicked and the humor because
right after I did the rally with Pat um
911 in New York City I'm also a New York
City public school teacher and the next
day my Edis was an Egyptian young man so
all these teachers were walking in Rosa
we saw you in the rally I was going like
this I you know but then you know what I
didn't care because the time had come
and I looked at him and and I said
kareim where do you stand on the mosque
because this is where I stand and he had
to respect where I stand on the map of
course and he gave me his answer but you
know what it opened the door to a
dialogue and we need to start if he's
secular I'm sure you know what but we
need to start they're moderates out
there we need to find them and we need
to start conversing because I've tried
to reach out to them myself I I speak a
little bit of Arabic but every time I
try to do they always get offended do it
in English you don't need to do it
in one more
question thought of
this here I've done a lot of work in
municipal government the question is I'm
sorry the question is why has this
territory around Ground Zero not been
declared a a historic preservation
district and why haven't covenants for
obvious reason being created where the
uh National Park Service would take over
zoning rules over this particular part
of Manhattan uh as a person active in
Minneapolis we deal with historic
National Historic preservation districts
all the time and I can tell you that
developers just are dve nuts by these
rules this would be a way that you could
limit the use of that property through
the federal government in bypass the
city
council thank you for that question the
answer to your question is that the uh
City landmarks preservation commission
is appointed by the administration of
the city of New York Mayor Bloomberg
appoints every single person on that
commission they held public hearings
several 911 families testified people
who are here Rosaline Talon myself many
other people testified we were speaking
to deaf ears political correctness is
what determined that this area was not
sacred ground as far as the National
Park Service the family members who have
labored since shortly after 911 to
declare Ground Zero a national landmark
and to have the a Park Service take it
over the answer The Unofficial answer
from the park service is that they don't
want to touch this issue with the 10t
pole it is it's it's so it's so
disheartening and finally and I know you
you want to uh make a comment finally
the name of this so-called Memorial and
museum is the national 911 memorial and
museum that is a Lie the National Park
Service has nothing to do with it it is
a name that was made up by the people
that control the city of New York and
Ground Zero That's the basis that
they're asking people like you
good-hearted people to give in money to
this it's a fraud it is it is not a
memorial in museum it's two pools of
water if there's a museum it's seven
stories under the ground it's it's you
will it's not a museum that has anything
to do with our loved ones there's a
picture there that's it if you want to
know how old my son is go to a kiosk and
look it up on a computer if you want to
know if he was where he worked look at
the kiosk if you want to know if he was
a fire fighter look in the kiosk it is a
disgrace it's a National Disgrace this
has to be made
public the family members who are here
we will never enter that building it is
dangerous and dishonorable to make the
families of the victims go 70 ft seven
stories underground one way in one way
out oh my God and finally they are
taking 16,000 human REM s that are now
in an area in Manhattan near the medical
examiner's office they're in
refrigerated trailers they're bringing
them down there for one reason they're
turning it into a ripes believe it or
not so good-hearted people like you will
pay $25 ahead to get in there to look at
a wall that says Behind These wall
there's
16,000 uh uh human remains and finally
no information about the dead these
heroic beautiful patriotics American
but the people who run the 9911 Memorial
Museum are going to have a wall that we
call the terrorist Wall of Fame with the
pictures of the terrorists and their
their last statements and all of their
motivation that's the God's honest truth
but they have succeeded in suppressing
all the atrocities about this Memorial
Museum and Daisy Khan is on the board
yes Daisy Khan is on the board and I'll
tell you one other thing before some
people were successful in having her
name removed she she had a space on the
Memorial website called Muslim voices
people were supposed to write in their
experience if they were a Muslim after
9911 if they had a bad experience if
they had a good
experience and a copy of all of these
experiences was to be copied to another
Muslim group so that they could keep it
for their records you know what this is
an atrocity we need your help to stop
this this is about our loved ones this
is not about anybody's
religion in this building today or will
be in this building tomorrow that
wouldn't mind Champion that sort of
legislation at the capital to bypass the
uh City Council in uh New York City or
any of the uh corrup bureaucracy that
lies there uh
also
wait well Michelle bman comes ladies and
gentlemen sir I want to take that for a
second I had a moment just a second ago
where Pamela invited me up to speak to
all of you and after hearing the
testimonies of all of these women there
was nothing that I could say that could
do anything more to honor the families
of all of you than just to tell you that
I will never ever forget but I want to
assure you that that there are members
of Congress that you all have elected
this last cycle like Alan West and
others that are going to fight this in
Congress and I just want to say one
thing to all of you that you have a call
to action to make you've heard people
weep you've been sitting here with me
weeping with them you have a duty that
when this movie is screamed tomorrow if
the room isn't standing room only and
people aren't lined up outside then you
have failed to do what your duty as
americ
12,000 in building and ask them each one
by one woman to woman man to man where
were you where were you on 911 and where
are you today ladies and gentlemen you
have a duty not just to never forget but
to never stop fighting do you understand
I want to help tell me what to do to
help I know this stupid question what
what do you need you come to us after
with your information of course any
actions that we do at at Atlas And gadat
if it's like Sally said you have to
write your Congressman but we're
actively involved in in in in fighting
this Masque so you do have to go to our
websites to see what actions we take we
did a rally last week demonstr against
the New York City Council because the
New York City Council is ancing The
Ground Zero Mas where they say it's not
government's business and they're
stopping Walmart so we there to point
out the hypocrisy we constantly are
fighting this m we need you if you're in
the New York area to come or we you know
we need you to write make a phone call
make make a phone call hold them
accountable because just because you're
not in the New York City question
affects all of us because where do we
where do we draw the L on and I want to
thank you very much I'm going to give
you my card I hope we can be in touch
yeah tell
websit Mayor Bloomberg if you will don't
have any more Mayor Bloomberg it's a
about time enough maybe we will have a
new may he will be not
soct yes young lady I love the bottom
line is that religion or no religion you
can worship a stone just don't Stone me
with it that's that's our platform um
I'm being told by management that we
have to close it up if you want to buy
the DVDs they're in the back uh $20 a
peace please come tomorrow please come
tomorrow and please set up set up a
screenings in your living rooms in your
libraries in your offices I will come I
will speak if you want me to in your
schools in your classrooms you have to
educate the people we you you are the
New Media every single one of you have
been activated now now do something
about
it oh oh Atlas shrug. jihadwatch.org
it's all there
[Applause]